a facebook whistleblower plans to
testify to congress this week that she
believes the company lies about how it
handles hate and misinformation former
facebook employee francis haugen
revealed her identity last night on 60
minutes her lawyers gave the securities
and exchange commission thousands of
pages of facebook's internal research
she says it proves the company knew its
algorithms raised the profile of hate
divisive political speech and
misinformation haugen also told scott
pelley that facebook chooses policies
that emphasize profit over public safety
so you know you have your phone you
might see only 100 pieces of content if
you sit and scroll off for you know five
minutes
but facebook has thousands of options it
could show you
the algorithm picks from those options
based on the kind of content you've
engaged with the most in the past and
one of the consequences of how facebook
is picking out that content today
is it is optimizing for content that
gets engagement or reaction but its own
research is showing
that content that is hateful that is
divisive that is polarizing
it's easier to inspire people to anger
than it is to other emotions
misinformation angry content
is enticing to people and
keeps them on the platform yes facebook
has realized that
if they change the algorithm to be safer
people will spend less time on the site
they'll click on less ads they'll make
less money
haugen says facebook understood the
danger to the 2020 election
so it turned on safety systems to reduce
misinformation
but many of those changes she says were
temporary and as soon as the election
was over they turned them back off or
they changed the settings back to what
they were before to prioritize growth
over safety and that really feels like a
betrayal of democracy to me
facebook told cbs news that quote the
growth of people or advertisers using
facebook means nothing if our services
aren't being used in ways that bring
people closer together that's why we are
investing so much in security that it
impacts our bottom line including the 40
000 people working on safety and
security at facebook and our investment
of 13 billion dollars since 2016.
the 60 minutes report also focused on
instagram which is owned by facebook
haugen says company research shows the
app can actually damage the mental and
physical well-being of teens in
particular teen girls
one of the facebook internal studies
that you found talks about how instagram
harms teenage girls oh yeah
one study says 13 and a half percent of
teen girls say instagram makes thoughts
of suicide worse
17 of teen girls say instagram makes
eating disorders worse and what's super
tragic is facebook's own research says
as these young women
begin to consume this eating disorder
content they get more and more depressed
and it actually makes them use the app
more
and so they end up in this feedback
cycle where they hate their bodies more
and more facebook's own research says
it is not just that instagram is
dangerous for teenagers that it harms
teenagers
it's that it is distinctly worse than
other forms of social media
you can read facebook's entire response
to 60 minutes on our website cbsnews.com
it's a powerful report facebook is part
of its uh response to 60 minutes says it
actually welcomes regulation
from congress i think there's reason to
take them at face value on that because
they're in a race for attention with a
lot of competitors
if there are rules for everybody to
follow they'll follow them too but in
the meantime they're being criticized
and asked essentially to make less money
and any company that has investors is
not going to voluntarily do that seems
counterintuitive when you hear what she
was saying that they would welcome
regulation
how what was she like what was her
position on mark zuckerberg well this is
very interesting she says mark she's
empathetic toward mark she doesn't think
mark was trying to create a a product
that hurts america uh or any other
society but he's running a business and
decisions have been made that have led
to bad outcomes so i think everybody
agrees regulation needs to come facebook
does congress does she does the question
is what should that regulation be
zuckerberg mark and the company seem to
be trying to tap it down but it doesn't
seem to be enough based on what she's
saying
it doesn't and by their own research i
mean like one of their reports said that
uh they estimate they get three to five
percent of hate speech off the platform
uh they also said they get six tenths of
one percent of violence and incitement
off the platform negativity hate speech
misinformation it all creates
conversation conversation creates
engagement engagement creates revenue
exactly it dials down well put to
revenue well put
yeah but some things are bigger than
revenue